[Music]
in an age of enormously complex often bewildering
technology the big shoulders don't count much
anymore the demand for unskilled physical labor
that america needed in its years of buildup
has shrunk to fit the horizons of a country that
must do the rest of its growing the
rest of its pioneering inside the city
november 26 79 home loans everyone
willing and able to work is entitled
to a decent job at a decent wage no job
life isn't much liberty is meaningless
and the pursuit of happiness has no steam
in it how about jobs for us if you don't
find a place for us and all this this
system how can you expect us to survive
jobs can be the solution to just about
everything that troubles us jobs can clean
up bad neighborhoods jobs can build up new housing
jobs can help us live and learn and eat and thrive
give people jobs and you've given
them more than just a livelihood
you've given them pride you've given them status
you've given them a stake in the country that's
what patriotism is really all about you love your
own you've given them more than mere citizenship
which some people thought back when they ratified
the 13th amendment was honor enough it wasn't it
isn't give people jobs and you've given them
membership participation belonging you've given
them purpose and hope give people jobs and
they'll take care of themselves and their own
chicago like america has always been a changing
place a city in the process of becoming [Music]
its early laborers and workmen learned for the
most part right on the job while they were doing
things we found this taking place during
the war when hitler and mussolini and tojo
were our number one enemies and we wanted to make
sure that we saved america for our posterity and
it was amazing how productive black workers became
we still need opportunities to learn on the job
more and more industries and unions are
recognizing this with dramatic results [Music]
the problem of equal job opportunity
for blacks is so multifaceted
that we have to attack it on many fronts no
one's going to get hired if they're not trained
but in some fields training is hard to come
by for minorities and women that's why we
started our apprenticeship outreach program in the
construction trades it's become a national model
to open up job opportunities in other
fields we have a very successful
employment service and we help companies
design workable affirmative action programs
small and large private enterprise flourishes in
many areas of chicago's black business community
nearly 10 000 black owned businesses make chicago
the nation's center of minority business activity
i